one day before he's available to meet
with reporters at otas it'll be the
first time he's spoken to the media
since the end of the season and
everything that's happened in the
aftermath by the way pfc live nbc sports
radio nbcsn hello to our friends in the
uk enjoying the show on sky sports chris
i know what ben's trying to do yeah
but
is he really going to change anyone's
mind
in
the locker room if there are guys
lurking there who are secretly aligned
with antonio brown and he surely still
has friends in the locker room is is
anything he said yesterday going to
change their minds especially when we
consider antonio brown's reaction which
was a two-word tweet two-face yeah well
it goes it starts the conversation i
mean again he could say all he wants and
everything like that and i think people
in the locker room are going to look at
that and go okay that's a start but
still he's going to be judged by the way
he treats and acts in the locker room
you know and again you know the first
time something bad happens during the
season is he going to take the blame
things like that hey really
ultimately here this is too little too
late as far as this apology for antonio
brown hey he was totally crazy with
calling antonio brown out not only
breaking the rules of the locker room
the man code whatever you want to say he
was just flat out wrong he threw an
interception to a defensive tackle i
don't know what angle he expected
antonio brown to run and if the
defensive tackle didn't intercept it
bradley roby was going to intercept it
too so it was a bad decision a bad throw
everything about it was bad and it was a
bad look for ben and i find it curious
that they're coming off the you know the
georgia lake house visit too i just
wonder if there was conversations with
some of the skill guys while he was
there i wonder if somebody called him
out a little and said hey you need to
own up to this it'll go a long way or
was this like you said all preordained
and he had this little interview
yesterday to lessen the blow of today's
media session or it could be a
combination and it could be that he
understands he's got work to do to
ensure that there aren't any
relationships within the locker room
that are secretly frayed you never know
what a guy really thinks
while you're working together right
except i tell you what i think of you
all the time but for the most part you
never really know what a guy thinks
until he's gone
and there may be other guys who who
can't at this point talk their way out
and tweet their way out of pittsburgh
and they're stuck with the circumstance
and it may be those guys that ben
rothberger has to identify and then try
to flip but consider this because i
think it's fair to look at what he said
and and
we we judge how sincere it all is by
assessing the accuracy of what he's now
saying his criticism of antonio brown in
the aftermath of that loss to the
broncos with the interception that was
thrown in the end zone by roethlisberger
he went on 937 the fan in pittsburgh and
said that antonio brown should have
flattened his route and not run to the
post we showed the replay just now on
nbcsn it was a horrible throw yeah it
wasn't a matter of how antonio brown ran
the route but but look at what
roethlisberger had to say about his
criticism of brown he said
i can see where that comment was
perceived to be negative towards a b but
it wasn't meant that way
it was more just like everything during
the season it's a compliment to a b
because he's double covered every single
play it's still so amazing is that he
was able to do it through all the
adversity of double and triple teams and
so it was more meant that i should have
gone to juju's miss shuster because he
was single covered i mean when you say
antonio brown should have flattened his
route
where is the i should have thrown the
ball to juju smith schuster it has
nothing to do with how antonio brown
runs his route it has everything to do
with a dumb decision that was made in
the moment to throw the ball to the
awaiting arms of a defensive tackle so i
think if the players who have misgivings
about roethlisberger study that yeah and
remember what he said in november
it's going to be a little bit harder to
mend fences if they hold him accountable
for this inconsistency because it's
pretty glaring to me yeah you're right i
mean there he is he's trying to be
accountable and as he's trying to be
accountable he takes a little bit of the
accountability off of himself and tries
to kind of blame it on some other
factors into the situation uh so yeah
player's gonna look at that and go wait
what the hell was that he's he's he's
apologizing and taking blame and then
he's kind of trying to disperse the
blame after that for other reasons
unbeknownst hey i know this for a fact
up in pittsburgh man everybody thinks
big ben is an awesome player they think
he's a baller i talk to players coaches
everybody is man big ben's amazing every
day in practice games whatever it may be
but in the locker room that is the issue
you know people walk on eggshells around
ben roethlisberger uh he's not always
great and just open as far as talking to
players and having conversations and if
guys ask for autographs he's not the
type of guy that's gonna just give it
away and and be like oh yeah no problem
i mean i've heard all these type of
things from him over the years uh so
he's gotta find a way to to open himself
up and be a little bit more of a friend
in the locker room i think more than
anything and stop being maybe the
general or the guy that points blame all
the time and everybody else and this has
been hanging around for years look
i mean i i i i think that we try to
strike the right balance between
praising him as a player but pointing
out the things that maybe he needs to
work on and he seems to be getting the
message the mere fact that he sat down
for this interview to the extent it just
wasn't a pr play and if he does actually
believe the things he was saying i am a
little bit concerned about the
inconsistency between the criticism of
brown and the effort to explain it away
but at least it shows he's becoming
self-aware and i think it it recognizes
that you know in these final years of
his career he needs all these guys to be
on the same page if he wants to add to
his legacy if he wants another super
bowl championship he's got to have his
teammates behind him all the way and he
can't be worrying about who secretly
doesn't like him and who's just waiting
for their opportunity to become a former
steeler so they can go scorched earth
about all the things ben did that they
didn't like well exactly and this is a
team again that you usually on a yearly
basis we're talking about as a super
bowl contender and camaraderie and
relationship and trust factor and the
ability to be on the same page with wide
receivers and running backs that could
be the difference in winning a game in a
big moment late in the season oh you
know i worked i had a lot of dialogue
with this guy all year on this route and
all of a sudden it showed itself in week
17 in a big moment and we were on the
same page why were we on the same page
man because i opened up and had a lot of
conversation with the guy and we really
knew what each other was thinking in
certain situations you know little
things like that go a long way you know
i look at like a guy like brady and
edelman i mean it's just not luck that
they always find each other in the
biggest moments game after game after
game no it's trust it's me knowing what
the other one's thinking it's trusting
the human and the football player and
that's part of football and it's part of
having a successful football team
chris the one moment i still can't get
past week 15 of the 2017 season after
the jesse james touchdown that was the
subject of an extended replay review the
steelers were aware that the ruling
could be overturned and they'd have to
go back out on the field they had three
minutes and 20 seconds
between plays and when you see the shots
of the sideline there was no ben
roethlisberger pulling all of his guys
together coaching staff pulling all the
guys together lining up two three plays
and when they finally went back out
there it was chaos and i think this
speaks to what you're talking about if
you have the right relationships with
your guys it happens you know to do it
everybody's on the same page everybody
gets together you're reinforcing these
things you have built from day to day
and week to week and time you spend away
from the facility working out time you
spend away from the facility hanging out
in those moments you have the awareness
to bring everyone together because i
think you feel that shared relationship
you've got that comfort level i don't
know am i reading too much into it no if
you have that right that right vibe
everybody does come together in that
moment and figures out what the hell
they're going to do when it's time to go
back out on the field yes yeah a hundred
percent you know again i'm gonna use new
england because they're the standard
they're the bar but i mean again i just
think if we went vice versa in that
situation and brady was sitting there
watching that replay and it was you know
them on the jesse james side of things
you know they would have come to reality
pretty soon oh this thing's going to get
overturned we got to figure out what
we're going to do and you know of course
it goes under the head coach too
belichick mcdaniels they all would have
started having a okay we got to get to
plan b this doesn't look good in that
case uh especially pittsburgh was just
hoping it didn't get over here oh i hope
we can beat new england i hope this
doesn't get overturned and they hoped so
hard there i guess there was no dialogue
or plan going forward and that was a
crap play a lot like the the denver
interception we saw this year was the
same thing one of those stupid slant
routes over the middle to where there's
10 people in the way and a lot of bad
things can happen
uh
another thing too here that it wasn't
part of the interview that was televised
last night on kdka but roethlisberger
also apparently told kdka that he hasn't
made a final decision about whether or
not he's going to continue this weekly
spot on 937 the fan in pittsburgh during
the season i had been told a few months
ago that he was thinking about not doing
it but he hadn't made a final decision
he still hasn't made a final decision we
talk a lot about it with my family and
my agents and the steelers i think
people like it that we can give some
inside access we'll make a final
decision moving forward if we do the
show it'll be the best we've ever done
if we don't there will probably be a
reason too yeah the reason is you're
saying things that are causing problems
in the locker room i mean it should look
mike tomlin should be able to say to ben
ben this is not a good idea not not that
tom has the ability to tell him not to
do it but the relationship between coach
and players should be if mike tomlin
says it's not a good idea roethlisberger
realizes it's not a good idea yeah i
wish somebody would say that to him i
wish big ben would realize that yeah
listen we it's really cool when when
quarterbacks do go on the radio and have
a you know 10 15 minute hit on a weekly
basis i get that but yeah big ben's
proven that that can cause some issues
with their football team in general and
you know again this is a team in
pittsburgh where
uh talk has been plenty there coming out
of that team i think less talk is good
for 2019. let's do less talk let's do
more playing let's not guarantee you
know new england afc championship games
and we're going to beat jacksonville and
all this other crap let's just play
football and stop worrying about the
press the media and some of the other
distractions that you know have annoyed
that organization over the last few
years
yeah and you know if you want to give
people inside access volunteer for hard
knocks right forget about the weekly
radio show during the football season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports